synthesis synthesize synthesizing to
take different pieces of knowledge and
be able to piece them together in novel
ways is amazing it's awe-inspiring it is
able to unveil new areas of knowledge
that have yet to be discovered if we can
figure out how we through history have
optimized synthesizing fields and
discovering new ones there'll be a
massive key to civilization of success
right now people are so deep in specific
fields people have always been either
deep in specific field or narrow on
maybe three fields or something how many
people have always been narrow on have
great breadth on like a hundred fields
or 500 fields or something like that how
many of these people are the ones that
can take something from poetry and mesh
it together with something from
neurobiology into something that awakens
a tremendous amount of people to the
importance of what actually is happening
inside of us and how we interact with
our environments these combinations are
so novel they're so beautiful and as a
new field emerges like the
decentralization technologies that that
then gets synthesized with all of the
other existing fields and then you find
even more new combinations that exist
synthesizing is one of the most
important things to do it also is what
we do every single day with when we
consolidate our memories when we go to
sleep that is a synthesis that's
occurring but to
what are inputs were of that day and the
previous inputs that we have had another
one is when you take something like the
edge that is being pushed in so many
different disciplines right now and you
uncover these new regions that have yet
to be pursued and that in itself is also
such an amazing and novel thing for us
to do it ok let's go back again in
history one more time take something
like when we're all together in either
the tribe days or in the initial days of
of cities and towns when we're there and
we have less of an edge that's being
pushed right decentralization technology
didn't exist or our understanding of how
to map the neural circuitry didn't exist
right so certain things just didn't
exist around the edge there were less
things to try and pair together less
permutations to run but now that the
knowledge graph has expanded in so many
new directions especially since the
Scientific Revolution that in some
regards though our spiritual line has
potentially even receded in some regards
because we may have been more
spiritually awakened to source God
creation before and now we're less
awakened to that with so many more
people and that's this grand challenge
that we face how do we awaken more
people to that but there's so many
permutations now there's so many ways to
explain dot or creation with so many
other potential fields that are around
the edge of knowledge so it's giving us
the potential to be able to synthesize
in new ways
in today's day with eight billion of us
with so many different fields now versus
the village days a tribe days town city
days that now we can unlock novel
synthesis
when we do that we also do things like
open up the edge of knowledge for other
young people to go and enter into and
pursue this becomes more and more
important because if you do something
like have a child that only has ten
options or 20 options and they only know
that they can go deep instead of they
also know that they can go wide with
great breadth then it restricts their
ability restricts their worldview when
they're only fed a certain worldview
every single day versus when they get a
second piece of the worldview a third
piece of fourth piece and then they're
able to see a while look at how this
eighth piece connects to the seventeenth
piece and now I synthesize those two and
it gives me a brand new awakened State
there's such important to synthesis it's
been happening for so long and
civilization and it seems like now we're
not taking these different aspects of
different fields not as much we're going
so deep in specific fields in many ways
we're going so deep in specific echo
chambers that we're forgetting to look
on the other aspects of the conversation
of the worldviews and then take those in
and see how it Nava Lee impacts us and
how that then can be used to awaken us
further
the synthesizing is again just one of
the most important things to be able to
do so take different worldviews take
different fields and start running all
of the different permutations and
combinations of these different fields
see what it gives you that's novel share
that with other people maybe there's a
way to blend together art into fields
that previously need never conceived
that could have had art or maybe there
are ways to blend in the the new fields
of automation into certain fields that
are repetitive work that people don't
want to do that we're not aware of yet
there's so many ways for us to run these
creative permutations but they have to
be more readily available and talked
about and explored and we have to make
it fun to synthesize we have to make it
fun to synthesize and fun to find these
novel combinations so let's do that
together I'm glad that we've had a bit
of conversation on synthesis is probably
the thing that runs my essence the most
right now is this big ultimate synthesis
of all that is into something that's
relatable for everyone that I'm super
excited to be doing it's the hardest
thing that I've ever done and it's
definitely challenging at times but it's
also extremely gorgeous and so to
synthesize even just two fields or try
all that is just try to synthesize it's
such a beautiful thing so talk more to
your friends families co-workers people
online about synthesizing take a field
look at the field and then bring into
another field into it in conversation
and just say hey how do you think this
field relates to that field hmm I don't
know yet well maybe you can do something
with that drone that's flying and maybe
you can capture something that's
absolutely gorgeous and inspiring and
then it can awaken more people maybe he
can work with nature who would have
thought that a drone could work with
nature well
person who saw a bird probably thought
of a drone maybe right in the way that
it stays up in the air so again these
are the ways that we can connect novel
fields bring them into your
conversations with people more often hey
hold on a second how does this random
field fit in mm-hmm if people say oh it
doesn't then they probably haven't
actually explored all of the
possibilities because there's almost
certainly always ways for different
fields to be combined in novel ways
again that's synthesizing that's the
synthesis that's why it's so important
get synthesizing more Big Love thank you
for tuning in if you haven't yet
subscribed leave us a comment we'd love
to hear from you also like the video
share it with other people we follow us
across other platforms we need to be
talking about these concepts more and
why they're so important for pushing the
edge of knowledge helping children see
things that they can synthesize at young
ages and going and pushing the edge
themselves think about all the
permutations that have yet to be
unlocked in civilization think about
that as a big knowledge graph that's
being pushed and all the question marks
around the outside that are not yet
there and go and push at those question
marks and discover new things
love you very much thanks for tuning in
see you soon peace